TOO.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED TO HIS HOME
CROWD
BLOCKER.
LOOKINGGICING AGAINST THE BLUE N
GETS A PIECE OF PUCK.
JACKETS LOOK TO COME OUT OF
THEI THE ICE
AND CAROLINA TERRITORY, ROBINSON
COMES
WORKS AGAINST ZACH WERENSKI TONO
NIEDERREITER.
>> Jeff: HE WINS THE DRAW,
RIGHT S
>> HOLDS OUTNG IT DONE, THEY ARE
CONFIDENT IN THEIR OPTIONS.. HIT
HIS FORMER MATES, THE 4-1 STAAL
>> Jeff:
YOU CAN SEE STAAL IN FRONT OF
KORPISALO AND WHEN HE POPS,. GE.
ICING THE CALL
THEY REALLY HAVE SOME MOMENTUM
ON THE PENALTY.
>> Jody: SEBASTIAN AHO WITH
ALL THAT TIME AND SPACE SHUFFLED
OUT OF THE NET COMES KORPISALO,
BLUE JACKETS.
SOME OF THE BEST OPPORTUNITIES .
WHIPPED AROUND ON THE ICE.FAILS.
>> Jeff: LAINE GATHERS THAT WINS
>> Jody: OUT OF THE ZONE IN
THIS TIME IT